[Música]
cuando era estudiante de medicina un
profesor nos preguntó
qué es el infarto agudo del miocardio
y respondimos casi sin pensarlo es la
necrosis la muerte del tejido cardíaco
muy bien nos dijo
pero si el tejido está muerto porque
duele tanto
nos quedamos mudos
sencillo
lo que duele es el tejido circundante lo
que está alrededor de lo muerto eso que
todavía está vivo si duele es que está
vivo
quiero hablar del dolor y también del
miedo pero veamos una escena lejos de la
facultad y mucho más cerca en el tiempo
algo que pasó hace muy poco el 8 de
marzo en un grupo de whatsapp alguien
manda un mensaje saludo por el día de la
mujer feliz día
las respuestas empiezan a caer
algunas en buen tono otras no tanto
haciendo referencia al origen histórico
de la fecha no particularmente feliz
el tipo en un varón
pide disculpas y enseguida aclara
ustedes saben que no soy para nada
machista saben desde donde lo digo
aparte voy a todas las marchas
después se llama silencio
el tipo que aclara que no es machista
que entiende las nuevas formas de
organización de las mujeres y que
acompañan sus cambios podría ser
cualquiera de los varones que estamos
acá
pero esto no nos pasa solamente a los
varones podrían ser mujeres porque lo de
atajar nos es algo que nos pasa a todos
cuando sentimos que podríamos meter la
pata
cuando nos estamos aventurando en
asuntos que están en plena
transformación nos sale esa especie de
aviso de advertencia para que no nos
hagan reclamos en el futuro es como
cuando se publicita una promo que se
escuche esa voz al final que dice oferta
válida en todo el país excepto a la
provincia de córdoba
es una suerte de términos y condiciones
que hacemos para aclarar que no somos
retrógrados y que acompañamos los
cambios sociales que estamos viviendo
sería algo así como aclaración válida
para toda situación en la que tenga que
opinar sobre un tema sensible sin quedar
como un fascista se reconocen haciendo
este tipo de avisos
cuando los hacemos no estamos de algún
modo definiendo el tipo de conversación
que queremos tener por ahí queremos
empatizar con la otra persona o que esa
persona no nos considere peligrosos
por ahí tenemos miedo de que nuestras
palabras se interpreten justo al revés
de lo que queremos decir cuál sería el
colmo de esos avisos en un programa de
televisión un periodista le preguntó una
chica cómo iba vestida cuando fue
acosada y en el zócalo de la pantalla
aparezca el número de teléfono para
llamar en caso de violencia de género
estar de acuerdo con los cambios no nos
libren principio de hacer esos avisos
hay una especie de resistencia al cambio
que se expresa de varias formas
aunque coincidamos nos cuesta a mí por
ejemplo me cuesta hablar diciendo
cheques y todos
lo veo forzado no me resulta cómodo
entiendo y comparto lo que se busca al
hablar así pero no me sale
al menos por ahora
sin embargo cada vez me cuesta más
escribir utilizando el masculino plural
extendido a todas las personas
entonces cada vez tengo más destreza
para evitarlo y uso mucho palabras que
no especifican género como gente
personas alguien pero no lo hago porque
está bien o porque es más correcto no me
sale ahora de otra forma una vez que lo
viste no puedes dejar de hablarlo
y si la forma en que hablamos o
escribimos afecta a nuestros vínculos
quizás al ser más inclusivo estoy
provocando menos dolor
en algunas personas
pero s vos sabés desde donde te lo digo
ese aviso del que hablábamos antes no es
algo que le pasa solamente a quien lo
dice es una experiencia que atraviesa a
todos los participantes de la
conversación
y es la expresión del destiempo que hay
entre los cambios que se van generando y
nuestra capacidad para metabolizar los
pero qué es ese destiempo veamos algunos
ejemplos
cuando se sancionó la ley de matrimonio
igualitario y un tiempo después la ley
de identidad de género estábamos
preparados para eso
qué significa estar preparados
la pregunta misma de si estábamos
preparados para eso podría resultar
ofensiva pero bueno ustedes saben desde
donde lo digo no
pero porque podría resultar ofensiva
imagínense que estamos
en múnich
es el 2 de octubre de 1946 ayer
terminaron los juicios de nuremberg
quiero entrar un café y me dicen que no
hagan tienen disculpas pero que todavía
no están preparados para recibir judíos
en su establecimiento que están de
acuerdo con todos los juicios pero que
necesitan tiempo
y tiempo
acaso las leyes están para contemplar lo
subjetivo y lo personal o justamente
indican la presencia de algo que marca
el final de un tiempo y el inicio de
otro
explícale a alguien que padeció toda su
vida prejuicios hostigamiento
discriminación que los demás necesitan
tiempo aprobamos el matrimonio
igualitario y ustedes hace 25 años que
están juntos pero el personal de
registro civil tiene que procesar esta
información
pero el asunto es más complejo
porque los vínculos las relaciones se
establecen entre personas diferentes que
están en momentos diferentes y que
experimentan el amor la libertad la
igualdad de formas distintas en mi
trabajo como terapeuta trato de ver qué
impacto tienen en nuestros vínculos
algunos de los cambios sociales de los
que somos testigos y también
protagonistas
estamos atravesando un cambio
paradigmático que a muchas personas les
duele y las violentas por resistirse al
cambio o por no tolerar la resistencia
de los que se resisten
y junto con el dolor está el miedo que
también es una señal de que algo está
pasando el miedo que muchas veces nos
paraliza no nos permite avanzar también
es una alerta de que hay adelante hay un
problema que hay que estar atentos y
hacer algo al respecto
pero el miedo es una experiencia
personal en cambio este dolor es una
experiencia colectiva que surge como
consecuencia del roce en los vínculos
por ejemplo sienten dolor quienes se
resisten a las nuevas formas del amor o
algunas notas nuevas pero que están
siendo muy civilizadas
y sienten dolor quienes entienden
que es inconcebible que esos cambios
todavía no se naturalizan del todo
pero los cambios están ocurriendo
y parece que se abre un camino que es
inexorable
y cuál es el problema
si los adultos especialmente los que
están a cargo instituciones no podemos
soportar este dolor las nuevas
generaciones van a perder eso que
pensamos fundamental esa mezcla de
límites y contención de afecto y
contexto normativo
para perder la alerta
quizás los actuales escraches
adolescentes sean entre otras cosas un
síntoma de ese otro síntoma la deuda de
los adultos y de las instituciones
se viene en épocas en las que vamos a
tener que conversar sobre cómo
conversamos y eso incluye hablar de
avisos y advertencias
gestos tonos de voz
y escuchar a los demás registrar las
tensiones
y el matiz del conflicto
como van a ser nuestras conversaciones
en un futuro cercano imaginen
conversaciones
difíciles pero no incómodas
respetuosas pero no políticamente
correctas conversaciones que causen
menos dolor
qué leyes qué palabras qué preguntas que
hoy ni imaginamos harán falta y cuáles
que existen no tendrán más sentido
en nuestras discusiones y en la
conciencia del destiempo está presente
el dolor
reconocerlo a tiempo y ponerlo en
palabras
es sabernos parte de un tejido que si
duele
está vivo
[Aplausos]
[Música]